una empresa de inversión crea un gráfico
que muestra el rendimiento de una acción
específica en un tiempo de 12 meses a lo
largo del año el precio de las acciones
está subiendo bajando o sigue siendo el
mismo bueno primero me dice mos que en
esta gráfica estamos comparando los
meses con su precio tenemos el mes julio
agosto septiembre octubre noviembre y
con sus respectivos precios en cada mes
por ejemplo en julio la acción vale
cerca de 10 pesos mientras que en agosto
la acción vale casi 11 pesos en agosto
está cerca de 11 pesos y así para cada
mes a esta gráfica se le conoce como
gráfica de líneas debido a que cada
punto en nuestra gráfica corresponde a
un mes específico con su respectivo
precio y todos los puntos se conectan
con una línea la razón de por qué se
conectan con una línea es porque existe
un accidente a tendencia y al unir todas
las líneas nos da la sensación de que el
precio se está moviendo a lo largo del
tiempo
ahora bien intentemos responder la
pregunta el precio de las acciones está
subiendo o bajando o sigue siendo el
mismo a lo largo del
y estoy haciendo énfasis en todo el año
porque si nos fijamos mes por mes por
ejemplo en el primer mes sube después
baja después en los siguientes dos meses
sube después vuelve a bajar después
vuelve a subir de febrero a marzo sube
de manera brusca y de marzo a abril baja
también de una manera brusca y después
vuelve a subir hasta que llegamos a
junio y bueno es que si nos pidieran el
análisis mes a mes ya lo tenemos muy
claro pero qué pasa si queremos el
análisis o la comparación del precio
inicial con el precio final a lo largo
de todo el año bueno para encontrar la
respuesta a esta pregunta vamos a
fijarnos en la condición inicial en
julio donde la acción valía 10 pesos a
partir de aquí aunque hubo momentos
donde bajó el precio de la acción
la tendencia general fue aumentar el
precio si nos fijamos por ejemplo en el
precio inicial de 10 pesos nos fijamos
por ejemplo en el precio final en junio
de casi 17 pesos la acción subió de
precio por lo tanto el precio de la
acción aumentó 7 pesos a lo largo de
este año es decir podemos concluir que
la tendencia de esta acción a lo largo
del año tiene una dirección hacia arriba
y esto se ve de manera inmediata
al ver la gráfica solamente pequeños
golpes en donde el precio de la acción
cae pero podríamos decir que de manera
general el precio de la acción se
mantiene creciendo